cette société avait pris l'habitude de
laisser les grandes décisions
économiques entre les maisons les
décisions qui se prenait dans golin soit
mal à montréal ou à toronto à londres à
new york mais pas de la communauté
encore retour sur la carrière de jacques
parizeau bien avant de faire le saut en
politique l'ancien premier ministre
conseiller en coulisses les artisans de
la révolution tranquille il a notamment
joué un rôle dans la nationalisation de
l'électricité dans les années 60 en tant
que conseiller du premier ministre jean
lesage
voici jacques parizeau le grand commis
de l'état en 1960 lorsque débute la
révolution tranquille
jacques parizeau a 30 ans et il est déjà
un professeur d'économie réputé bientôt
il sera recruté par le gouvernement
lesage pour construire l'état moderne du
québec
il sera le penseur derrière la création
de la société générale de financement et
de la caisse de dépôt et placement
l'idée lui est venue lorsque le monde
des affaires de montréal et toronto
dominés par des anglophones et regrouper
un syndicat financier a voulu bloquer la
nationalisation des compagnies
d'électricité par hydro québec
vous voulez pas prendre 30 à des
conditions raisonnables parfait
à quel moment à quelles conditions ils
sont tus marché mais on ne veut plus
qu'un seul gros elle n'a pas le désir d
enfants et d empreintes du verbatim voté
le 23 juin 65 la loi un petit noir laqué
de dépôt et de placement du québec
prendra effet le 1er janvier prochain
quand le syndicat s'est rendu compte
qu'on avait une alternative
ils se sentent tout fait tout air nous
on fait des conditions non n'a jamais
oublié dans l'eau sans toujours avoir
une alternative
pour en parler j'accueille avec plaisir
de personnes qui connaissent bien ce
plateau et le téléjournal à québec qu'un
ancien très proche conseiller de jacques
parizeau jean françois lisée bonsoir
bonsoir cd est avec moi sur ce plateau
biographe auteurs anciens collègues
aussi pierre duchesne bonsoir bonsoir
alors jean-françois je vais commencer
avec vous parce que jacques parizeau en
fait dans la vie leur effet pu faire
beaucoup d'autres choses que de devenir
fonctionnaire selon vous quelle était la
lave ou la motivation profonde qu'il
avait de devenir mon arrêt l'ugta a été
et c'est tout à fait vrai que toute sa
vie
jacques parizeau savais qu'il y avait
une autre vie parallèle possible qu'il
aurait pu faire
moi j'ai je sais que le président le
gouverneur de la banque du coeur dans
des années 50 où monsieur parizeau a
fait un travail pendant un certain temps
a confié à son fils qu'il avait vu en ce
jeune économiste diplômé du london
school of economics
un futur gouverneur de la banque du
canada alors si jacques parizeau n'avait
pas décidé de devenir souverainiste en
1963 il aurait pu devenir ministre des
finances du canada président de la
banque royale il aurait pu devenir un
grand magnat de la finance canadienne ou
internationales faire des millions de
dollars mais il a choisi à la place une
quête beaucoup plus ardu mais qui le
satisfaisait personnellement celle d'un
québec indépendant et c'est tout à son
honneur et à ce moment là on est
vraiment dans le maître chez nous de
jean lesage
on parle de libération économique et lui
il veut jouer un rôle là dedans mais ce
qu'il y avait de l'exagération l'attend
quand on parle de libération
pas du tout parce que jacques parizeau
avant d'être aspiré par la révolution
tranquille
ils travaillent par exemple comme
consultant pour la compagnie alain
compagnie de pâtes et papiers
c'est un milieu dominé par
l'establishment anglo saxons et il
s'aperçoit lors d'une réunion avec un
cocktail pendant un cocktail que le
dirigeant de domtar se valent de dire on
réussit à maintenir les canadiens
français à un niveau pas plus élevé que
des contremaîtres et c'est comme ça
qu'on maintient notre domination et
philippaerts tahrir il s'aperçoit que le
jeune homme qui est à côté de qui parle
anglais avec un accent britannique
c'est un québécois francophone licence
excuse jacques parizeau jean-françois
par le talent de ses travaux à la banque
du canada faut comprendre que lorsqu'il
revient qui sont docteurs de la london
school les premiers québécois décès le
premier québécois canadiens français à
avoir un diplôme london school un
doctorat à 24,1 faut le faire et les
premiers travaux qui lui confie la
banque du canada là c'est de traduire en
français des rapports annuels
alors ça vous donne une idée du type de
pays dans lequel on est puis les
propriétaires des entreprises on parlait
du dos l'écrit cité tout à l'heure ce
sont des compagnies anglo-saxonnes qui
maintienne des tarifs élevés pour les
citoyens les petits des petits
consommateurs les pme et très bas pour
les industries c'est le contraire de ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui parce que les
actionnaires des compagnies
d'électricité sont aussi actionnaires
des compagnies industrielles
bon alors les pression était très forte
pour empêcher la création de la caisse
de dépôt par exemple jean françois mais
même jean lesage avait des réserves et
c'est jacques parizeau qui va être le
moteur vraiment c'était une énorme
audace de se penser qu'un gouvernement
qui n'avait pas une grande expérience
dans les affaires
d'ailleurs les ministres des finances
étaient des anglophones jusque là à les
nationaliser tout une ressource
naturelle appartenant à des canadiens
des américains des britanniques et ou à
l'eau ou à lyon nous trouver l'argent
pour ça c'était la grande question et
jacques parizeau parce qu'il était né
dans l'argent dans une famille riche
n'avait pas peur des forces de l'argent
parce que il était allé au london school
lui il avait le dip longue de la
métropole de l' empire britannique alors
il regardait ses financiers canadiens
anglais qui était finalement des
coloniaux 1 du canada et des deux mois
jean c'est assez sur les finances
internationales pour vous dire qui en a
de l'argent pour financer une chose
comme celle d'autres pays dans le monde
d'autres provinces ont nationalisé leur
hydroélectricité alors si vous voulez
pas jouer avec le gouvernement lesage
c'est ce que vous nous dites je vais
aller à new york où il ya des gens qui
vont vouloir nous prêter de l'argent
alors pour québécois de l'époque avoir
l'audace le courage de dire une chose
pareille de se sentir capable de le dire
et d'être traités de tous les noms par
l'establishment anglophones dans les
journaux
était ostracisés dans le milieu
financier anglophone de montréal
ça prenait énormément de confiance en
soi et s'il n'y avait pas eu des gens
comme lui et d'autres comme michel
bélanger qui ont dit à lesage et qui ont
dit à l'évêque on veut réussir ça
peut-être que ça se serait pas fait
rapidement bien parce qu'après on va
passer à la partie politique on peut on
peut ajouter sur le contexte de l'époque
il dirige une revue économique
l'actualité économique de la chaussée
ils essaient de vente une des seules
revue francophone
ils essaient d'en vendre l'université
mcgill et megal refuse même de le mettre
dans le présentoir jugeant que c'est pas
pertinent parce que c'est français lui
arrive de londres avec un diplôme il ya
même eu des diplômes aussi de la france
alors il va ce qui va arriver ce qui est
inspiré par révolution la révolution
tranquille
il voit bien tout le dynamisme et il met
sur pied avec d'autres bien sûr mais la
sgf la caisse de dépôt pour enfin
contrer ce chantage financier et avoir
une source de revenus autonomes qui fait
concurrence à celle de des marchés
financiers qui freinent souvent pièce
est très d'actualité là aujourd'hui
délit grands groupes financiers freine
sur un gouvernement qui veulent amener
des politiques progressistes fascinant
quand même et on va parler maintenant de
la contribution de jacques parizeau au
monde politique avant je propose un bref
rappel en 1969
le parti québécois vient tout juste
d'être fondées lorsque jacques parizeau
se joint à l'équipe de rené lévesque
la raison pour laquelle je suis rentré
un policier c'était que je voulais
en 1976 le pq est porté au pouvoir et le
brillant économiste deviennent
naturellement ministre des finances
l'option du non l'emporterait malgré la
défaite référendaire de 1980 il demeure
aux commandes jusqu'en 1984 quand rené
lévesque accepte la main tendue par
brian mulroney pour une réconciliation
avec le canada de toute évidence eu un
élément de risque mais c'est un boris la
suite de la défaite de l'accord du lac
meech jacques parizeau revient en
politique comme chef du pq ne reprend le
pouvoir et organise en 1995
un second référendum sur l'indépendance
du québec
le remercie tous ceux et toutes celles
qui ont fait avec moi je bout de chemin
ou lendemain de la défaite crève coeur
jacques parizeau quitte la politique
pour de bon mais la politique en soi un
métier quand j'ai trouvé détestable des
stages et celui-ci est de toucher
rapports inter personne du conflit
l'épisode de 10 est un océan d'orteils
un océan d'orteils gens faisant il
aimait pas le métier de politicien mais
la politique pour lui c'était quand même
un moyen d'arriver à ses fins non il
adorait ils adorent l usage du pouvoir
pour la transformation économique et
social économique on le dit tout à
l'heure il est un de ceux qui ont fait
en sorte que la le gouvernement
québécois l'état québécois est donne des
leviers à la majorité francophone et
lorsqu'il devient ministre des finances
il décide de créer avec les régime
d'épargne-actions une nouvelle
génération de québécois qui ne s'y
connaissait absolument pas en bourse et
qui ont capitalisé des moyennes
entreprises jean coutu cascades
bombardier cgi snc-lavalin qui sont
devenus des géants
alors il n'est plus rien québec d'anor
et les l'accoucheur d'une toute une
classe économique moderne au québec et
c'est le paradoxe de voir que ces
entreprises allaient s'opposer à son
projet de souveraineté en 95 est dans le
camp du non mais c'est lui qui les avait
pas enfanter mais il y avait suscité
leur développement par ces mesures
vécu ça comme une trahison il lui il
avait dit il y avait qui crache dans la
soupe dans un moment de vraiment de
mauvaise humeur
c'est comme si toutes ces années avant
qu'ils soient finalement premier
ministre pour préparer son référendum il
y avait tenté d' habiller le québec déjà
de mantoue d'une cuirasse qui serait
propre à celle d'un pays un pardon d'un
pays et la caisse de dépôt il participe
il dessine les plans d 1,60 phase ii il
devient ministre des finances il se
lance dans des grandes opérations avec
jean campeau qui préside la caisse la
caisse va acheter va acheter gaz métro
va acheter une minière va acheter
plusieurs entreprises importantes
il vaut même moment donné à lire merci
le canadien pacifique pour acheter des
actions et à ce moment là le canada
l'establishment de toronto vont bloquer
vos même convaincre le sénat d'adopter
une loi de menacé d'adopter une loi et
ce 31 contre la caisse de dépôt alors
jacques parizeau voulait donner de la
confiance aux québécois en créant des
institutions mais aussi en étant à
l'offensive en achetant des entreprises
canadiennes importante et y miser là
dessus bien sûr en disant mais par la
suite si jean rené lévesque a joué sur
la fierté mais jacques parizeau c'est la
confiance en soi et une certaine
puissance économique mais c'est une
icône unique
oui bon jacques parizeau aura pas réussi
on en a beaucoup parlé ça lui a beaucoup
coller à la pole qui n'a pas réussi à
réaliser son objectif il a eu cette
phrase malheureuse me soit ce fameux
soir là vous étiez avec lui jean
françois alors qui la polluent le
discours que vous lui aviez préparé
c'est sa prérogative mais j'aimerais
dire on parle beaucoup d'économies mais
il ya tout l'aspect social de son
travail comme premier ministre la loi
sur l'équité salariale la perception
automatique des pensions alimentaires
les carrefours jeunesse emploi c'est lui
allons y avait une volonté de aussi de
faire monter le dos de droits des femmes
qui est important le soir de 95 bein
c'est tout ce prix qu'il avait payé pour
être le chef des souverainistes les
orteils qu'il avait dû
éviter d'écraser et tout ça n'avait pas
de donner la victoire qu'ils voulaient
nous ont trouvé que c'était quand même
extraordinaire d'être passée de 40% à 80
à presque cinq ans pour 195 donc c'était
une étape de plus
mais pour lui c'était comme un échec
personnel et c'est cette tristesse qu'il
a qui l'a exprimé de façon maladroite ce
soir là et il avait vu ce soir à la
victoire il pensait que c'était possible
de caresser le pays et coûté la wii
dominé pendant un certains nombres d'une
période quand même assez longue mais du
québécois ce qu'ils ont vu ce soir là
c'est ce qu'ils souhaitent aussi c'est
un leader authentique qui dit les choses
avec clarté et jacques parizeau est en
clair et un homme de conviction et en
eux n'étant pas l'homme des demi mesures
quand il gagne il triomphe quand il perd
il est en colère et ce soir et il a
perdu
et en plus il a une énorme blessure en
lui parce qu'il y avait mis trois caps
des saignées les meilleures années de sa
vie toute son intelligence à un projet
qu'il souhaitait il y avait engagé un
dialogue avec les québécois donc
certaines c'était une douleur mais il a
ouvert son poids taille aux québécois je
pense pour mu reste très peu de temps
une phrase chacun qu'est ce que vous
retenez de lui jean françois jacques
parizeau laissé ses empreintes digitales
sur tout le québec moderne
donc il va nous accompagner pour des
générations encore étonné mange vu comme
un grand bourgeois l'homme au complet
trois pièces c'est un homme d'une grande
sensibilité
un homme passionné pour les siens et qui
aura été avant tout généreux merci
beaucoup à vous deux lavoirs et
terrasses ce soir avec nous fait
vraiment rêver
merci merci sénat